what if instead of shining brightly for
another 5 billion years the only star in
our solar system turned into a dark and
cold remnant a black dwarf how long
would the earth last without all the
heat and light it gets from the Sun and
how would the Sun going dark change the
universe this is what if and here's what
would happen if our Sun turned into a
black dwarf all stars have an expiration
date
they don't just fade to black though
stars like our Sun don't have enough
mass to become a neutron star they end
up expanding to red giants and then
shedding their outer layers until only
their core remains that's when they
become white dwarfs white dwarfs don't
have fusion reactions fueling them up
they gradually cool down until one day
they become black dwarfs the thing is
there are no black dwarfs anywhere in
the universe
black dwarfs just haven't formed yet you
see white dwarfs may not produce any
energy but they still have enough of it
left to keep them shining faintly for
hundreds of billions of years given that
the universe is only 13.8 billion years
old even the oldest white dwarfs are
still glowing at temperatures of a few
thousand degrees Kelvin in the case of
our Sun it will take another quadrillion
years for it to cool down and become a
black dwarf that's 1 million million
million million years from now give or
take a few millions think humans will be
around for that long
well let's switch it up what if the Sun
burnt out tomorrow I hope you have a
good supply of batteries on hand because
the entire solar system would be thrown
into darkness put on a few sweaters
because it would become much colder to
Planet era Lee speaking we're pretty
spoiled here on earth with all the heat
and light provided by the Sun we're able
to make a comfortable home on a rock
hurtling through space at 110,000 km/h
it's easy to forget there were just
another speck in the universe but if the
Sun stopped burning it would
be immediately evident that we're just
floating in space after the first week
without the sun's heat the Earth's
surface temperature would drop to zero
degrees Celsius after a year it would go
down even more dropping to a freezing
cold minus 100 that is if the Sun turned
into a black dwarf instantly which is
unlikely even for our hypothetical
scenario realistically to become a black
dwarf the Sun would have to go through
all stages of the stellar life cycle
from the main sequence star it is now
the Sun would expand into a red giant
fade out to a white dwarf state and only
then cool down to become a black dwarf
at the red giant stage it would bake the
earth most likely swallowing it
completely along with Venus and Mercury
at least we wouldn't have to worry about
freezing to death once the Sun shrank to
a black dwarf what about the rest of the
planets the ones lucky enough to have
evaded the burning flames of the red
giant well they keep orbiting that
remnant of the Sun as if nothing had
happened even though the Sun would
shrink to the size of the earth its mass
would stay the same meaning that its
gravitational pull would remain
unchanged in the grand scale of the
universe the death of the Sun wouldn't
change anything either the Sun would be
just another star to go dark to small
and insignificant to make the universe
even a tiny bit darker but what if all
the stars died at the same time well
that's a story for another what-if
[Music]